okay let's play uh
mister green knight
[Music]
this is a sink no no increment game as
well
yeah so we have to
we have to play fast and this guy is
obviously very
very experienced user so he will play
fast as well
[Music]
what he was probably hoping for me to
prevent bishop g7 because otherwise this
makes exactly zero sense
knight is 3 okay fine
b5 was probably a good move as well but
there is nothing wrong with playing
schematically bishop g7 f5 and stuff
so this is the one i played few times in
the
magnus invitational and the previous
tournament
whatever it was i mean air sinks or
something i don't even remember
i don't even remember the titles
okay let's play rugby and before was
also interesting but i
i mean once again i don't feel like we
need to
prove anything here
this is just very comfortable for black
it takes a five this is a really brave
move i'm gonna say
so knight b4 is an option rookie check
is an option
um knight d4 is kind of an option as
well
[Music]
okay it feels like we have to play
knight before
and then after bishop d3 we'll have a
billion of
moves again
and this is a real billion in fact okay
we can
play rook takes c3
bc bishop c3s and b super a1
we can also play like bishop takes
three bc rook takes 3 which is obviously
rock solid
you can also play some rocket
okay let's not forget this is um no
increment game so
let's just do something
he goes there well this is definitely a
mistake
now i just take and i think black is
just better
okay but then we have rookie two and we
win one more pawn
which should be important
okay return takes f2 is a thread
and then we start running pawns i
believe
and four okay what i like about this
position is it's kind of easy to play
okay h3 i know what the plan is
go a3 a2 and queen
go there okay then you go b5 b4
b3 and queen
okay let's take just in case
h6 doesn't make any sense
i don't see it actually okay let's say i
think
he probably wants to check meters
somehow but
like that would take a lot from both
sides
okay let's go to g7 once again just in
case
our ob1 looks good enough
okay let's say we take rugby one
okay i have 33 seconds come on brother
sometimes yeah sometimes you can resign
thanks for the game